えー人間誰しも
聞いてみたくないですか？
結局そういうギャップにみんな萌え…
「ギャップ萌え」ですね。
ギャップ萌えとか、普段しないような
普段怒らないような人が怒るから怖い。
普段厳しい人が優しくされるから
キュン♡
というように、
その人が言わないようなことを言わせると
というわけで今トミックさんが上にいるんですけども
まあ今回は
普段の
元から汚いみたいだ…
普段のトミックさんが絶対言わないようなセリフを言わせて、
もっとトミックさんの素敵な部分を皆さんに知ってもらいたい。というわけで
今回の企画は
トミックさんが言わなさそうなセリフを言わせた瞬間、この動画は終わります。
はい、もうそういう企画です。
で、先ほどツイッターのほうで少し募集をかけたんですけども
やべぇ、ちょっと色々ありすぎて難しいな～
送ってくださった皆様ありがとうございました
結構色々あるんですけども
「dope」か…あーなるほどなるほど
「dope」言わなさそうだなあ。
とりあえず上から見た時に一番いけそうなのは
ここらへんかな。
「トミカ」とか言わなさそうですよね。
トミックさん普段魚の動画出してるんで
たぶんトミカ…おもちゃのことはあんまり言わないと思うんで
「トミカ」狙いでいってみたいと思います
ではいこう
（はじめ）ブゥゥゥン！！ブンブン！！ブンブン！！（トミック）なに？
（はじめ）車だぁい！ブブン！ピピィ！ブブン！ブンブン！
（はじめ）ブンブン！ブンブン！
（トミ）なになになになに
（はじめ）ブンブン！ブゥン！ブゥン！
（トミ）なにそれ？
（はじめ）ブゥン！車、ブゥン！
(トミ)  いや、車買えよwww
(はじめ)  ブゥン…
（はじめ）ブゥン！
（はじめ）ブ ブゥン！　ブンブン！
（はじめ）おおおおぉい！！！
（トミ）なに？
（はじめ）おいトミック。
（トミ）それともなんだよ
（はじめ）それとも
（はじめ）名誉か
（トミ）名誉しかないの？
（はじめ）地位か
（はじめ）名誉か、あと…
（はじめ）デュデュン！
(トミ)  何？
（トミ）はい（はじめ）あのー…
（トミ）おぉぉ…
（はじめ）あのー
（トミ）ヘジュミン？！
（はじめ）ユアネィム？ユアネィムイズ？
（はじめ）ノゥノゥ
（はじめ）ハ…ヘ、ヘジュミン
（トミ）なんて？！
（はじめ）イェイェイェア
（はじめ）ブゥン！ブンブンブーン！
（はじめ）ブゥン！
（はじめ）てやぁぁぁぁぁ！
（トミ）…遊んでないで準備したら？
（はじめ）いや、本気ですって僕は
（トミ）…準備に本気もくそもある？！
（はじめ）トミックさぁん？（トミ）ん？
（はじめ）なんか名称…愛称みたいな
（はじめ）車のニックネームみたいな（トミ）あぁ…
（はじめ）トミック…カー……なんかいいのねぇかな
（はじめ）だぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！
（はじめ）くそー、どうすりゃええんや
（はじめ）仲よく遊ぶみんなの車♪
（トミ）あー違う違う違う
（トミ）あれでしょ？
（トミ）トゥットゥルットゥ～でこの三角からでてくるやつでしょ？
（トミ）のりものあつまれ♪
（トミ）いろんなくるま♪
（トミ）あ、どんどん出てこい♪
（トミ）はたらく（二人）くるま♪
（はじめ）はぁ～…
（はじめ）んー、都民？
（トミ）そう、都民
（はじめ）もぉ～どうすりゃええんや
（トミ）なにどうした？
（はじめ）どうしたらええんや、ほんと
（トミ）なにどうするの？
（はじめ）くっそぉぉ・・・
（はじめ）あー、ブーブーで遊びたいの、ブーブー
（トミ）車？（はじめ）あのブーブーで遊びたいの！
（はじめ）あの！あのブーブーで遊びたい！
音楽(ENDING )
（トミ）ブゥゥゥ？
ブゥン！ブ～ン
ブゥゥ～
ブゥ～ゥゥ…
ブ～ン
（トミ）ちょっと地味にくすぐったい